[Musique]
dans ce que vous avez de ce tantôt mais
là vous avez même pas le réflexe de
faire le 91 c'est plus
[Musique]
vingt ans cette mère était fortement
soupçonné d'avoir assassiné son fils
est-ce que notre système de justice est
allé au fond des choses
[Musique]
il s'appelait Jean Patrick Géraud si
garçon de 3 ans et demi des médecins
québécois et français s'affrontent dans
une bataille d'experts je suis certaine
qu'il est mort je suis absolument
certaine
au cœur du dossier de la mort du petit
Jean Patrick l'expertise contestée d'une
pathologie stock québécoise Annie
Sauvageau
ici sauf ce rapport qui n'arrivait pas à
conclure et devinez quoi c'est la même
année Sauvageau qui a témoigné pour la
belle-mère de la petite fille de Granby
et le débat sur ses compétences a failli
faire avorter le procès ici Marie Maud
Denis bienvenue à enquête
c'est l'histoire que nous n'aurions pas
dû vous raconter le mystère qui n'avait
peut-être pas lieu d'exister un crime
odieux commis ici à Montréal mais
résolus ici à Paris presque 20 ans plus
tard
deux longues décennies pendant
lesquelles cette femme
n'a pas eu à répondre de ses actes
de quoi qui est mort ce matin
vous venez d'assister aux premières
secondes d'un moment rarement vu à la
télévision une mère est interrogée
pendant 4 heures sur les circonstances
du décès de son propre fils moi je vous
confirme
concernant sa mort je vous comprenais ça
clairement d'accord
vous êtes vous êtes un suspect possible
dans l'enquête qu'on fait parce que la
dernière personne qui était avec
Jean-Patrick quand l'événement t'a aidé
de quoi cet enfant est-il mort c'est la
question centrale de cette histoire
celle qui obsède le détective Yves
Beaulieu
Marie-Christine Bugeaud était seul avec
son fils lorsqu'elle le trouve mort dans
son lit sans cause apparente au matin du
9 novembre 2002 Jean Patrick Giraud
avait trois ans et demi
son père se souvient du moment où le
monde a basculé
j'ai changé de couleur et ça a été un
énorme choc et plus rien
plus rien ne sera jamais comme avant la
vision du monde change totalement
[Musique]
cette histoire je possède c'est la fin
de trois vie la fin de la vie du fils
celle de la mer et aussi celle du père
en 2002 Julien Giraud un conseiller
financier
issu d'un milieu aisé habité à Paris il
visitait son fils tous les deux mois à
Montréal ou là j'ai jean-Patrique et sa
mère le couple était séparé entre les
parents le conflit est ouvert et
explicite
je voulais qu'il voit son petit mais je
voulais juste qu'il sorte de ma vie
comme menace
je croyais pas qu'elle pouvait aller
jusque là mais je pensais que elle était
parfaitement capable de prendre l'enfant
de disparaître au Mexique ou quelque
chose comme ça et puis aller la
retrouver enfin je pensais à quelque
chose comme ça
c'est un nazi que le couple s'est
rencontré elle est avocate pour une
société chinoise il est directeur
financier à Hong Kong on était deux
francophones
isolés d'ailleurs mais bon
c'est sûr on a sympathisé et puis voilà
les choses se sont faites rapidement
quoi après une grossesse imprévue
Jean-Patrick n'est au Québec en 1999 à
ce moment-là ses parents sont déjà
séparés
j'étais présent lors de sa naissance
on m'a fait couper le cordon
ombilical qui défait
se sentit très très vite un lien assez
fort vis-à-vis de
vis-à-vis de ce bébé
Marie-Christine Bugeaud était elle aussi
très attachée à l'enfant un attachement
d'ailleurs qui allait vers l'exclusif
quoi c'est comme si elle devait avoir le
monopole de de l'accès ou de l'accès au
bébé quoi même même le prendre en photo
c'était c'était compliqué en fait tout
devient rapidement compliqué entre les
deux parents moi monsieur c'était déjà
au bout de ma corde en janvier pourquoi
j'étais au bout de Mako je dormais pas
de nuit depuis 3 ans mon petit me
réveillait toutes les
juste aller travailler comme avocat
m'occuper d'un jeune enfant puis de me
faire harceler constamment par le père
mais qui harcelait qui dans cette
histoire
Marie-Christine Bugeaud accuse Julien
Giraud d'être un père incompétent et
dangereux elle dépose des dizaines de
recours et de plaintes au tribunal à la
police et à la DPJ tous sans résultat et
elle emmène constamment son fils au
bureau du médecin
d'après vous là
la réponse est saisissante comme on le
voit dans l'enquête de police plus de 80
consultations auprès de 52 médecins
différents pour un enfant qui ne
souffrait d'aucune condition médicale on
peut pas à 80 ou 90 reprises à des
consulter tout un tas de médecins dans
des endroits très différents du reste
pour des pathologies complètement
différentes ça c'est déjà un trouble
psychiatrique qui émerge et qui devrait
alerter qui devrait planter un drapeau
rouge pour les enquêteurs en 2002 le
comportement de Marie-Christine Bugeaud
inquiète son entourage de plus en plus
deux fois elle emmène son fils en France
et propose la garde à la famille du père
puis à une cousine avant de changer
d'avis
pour Julien Géraud c'est le point
tournant et ça c'est compliqué beaucoup
dans sa tête pour qu'elle fasse ça
ça devenait elle devenait incohérente
quoi j'ai demandé du point de vue
judiciaire que la gare de Maurice ne
soit confiée parce que je pensais que
ça allait plus du tout du côté de la mer
à Montréal les deux parents se
soumettent à une évaluation
psychologique ordonnée par la Cour la
psychologue remarque l'intelligence vive
de la mère et ses capacités parentales
mais aussi un dénigrement obsédant et un
rejet du père visant à l'éliminer de la
vie de l'enfant ceci est un danger
significatif
en quelques jours elle révoque la
psychologue se plaint à la police et
saisit le tribunal d'urgence mais rien
n'y fait le juge autorise le père à voir
son fils dès le lendemain
les visites allaient commencer et à ce
moment-là pour elle c'était le danger
absolu elle n'avait plus la maîtrise
elle n'avait plus la possession totale
de en fait son fils je pense était une
extension d'elle-même la visite perd
fils et prévue pour le samedi mais dans
la nuit de vendredi la voisine du dessus
est réveillée soudainement j'ai entendu
un cri qui m'a réveillé entre 3 et 4
heures du matin c'était comme des
gargarismes comme s'il s'étouffait ça a
duré trois ou quatre minutes
décrit de l'écume dans le nez de
l'enfant et une serviette mouillée dans
son lit plusieurs indices pointe les
policiers vers une noyade dans la
baignoire sa mère n'a rien vu rien
entendu je m'approche de lui je lui
prends la main elle est froide
je lui touche les joues elles sont
froides je mets mon oreille sur son cœur
j'entends rien
je mets ma bouche vis-à-vis sa bouche il
y a pas derrière
je voulais pas croire on le sait là
ce que Marie-Christine Bujo n'a pas fait
ses contacter le 911 elle appelle
d'abord une amie et lui demande de
passer d'urgence pour le détective Yves
Beaulieu qui l'interroge depuis trois
heures c'est incompréhensible
une partie de son corps qui serait
froide là ma main sera sur le téléphone
pour faire le 91 dans les secondes qui
suivent
quand je débarque à son bureau
et je lui ai dit
si j'étais pas venu il serait temps vie
et elle m'a répondu
si j'avais pas envoyé mon rapport il
serait temps vie alors on s'était
parfaitement compris sans dire sans en
dire beaucoup on s'était compris
[Musique]
retour de quoi est mort Jean Patrick
c'est un mystère au Québec mais pas en
France
elle a réveillé où au milieu de la nuit
et puis elle la noyée dans de la
baignoire
[Musique]
la mort du petit Jean Patrick Giraud et
comme vous l'avez vu plus que suspecte
son père va s'entourer de sommité pour
prouver que son fils a été assassiné
tous les jours dans des salles comme
celle-ci Caroline Rambaud cherche la
réponse à une question fondamentale
pourquoi cette personne est-elle morte
[Musique]
dans cette salle de l'hôpital Raymond
Poincaré repose trois victimes d'une
mort violente ou suspecte autour des
corps les médecins s'activent et les
détectives observent docteur Rambaud et
médecin légistes pathologistes
pédiatriques une des plus expérimentées
de France on est au cœur de ce qui se
passe dans la vie et on peut savoir
pourquoi le pourquoi des choses et
pourquoi la personne est morte et donc
ça apporte des réponses
pour élucider la mort d'un enfant une
spécialité rare et complexe la justice
française fait souvent appel au docteur
Rambaud et à sa conso la pédiatre et
médecin légiste Caroline Ray salmon nous
les avons retrouvé au Musée d'Histoire
de la Médecine de Paris médecin des
armées et pop-charles 10 trous du
docteur en Thomas ayant servi pour le
toxine Napoléon 1er à Sainte-Hélène
orphyla ça c'est précieux dis donc
peut-être qu'on trouverait un peu
d'arsenic dessus une seule fois dans
leur carrière les deux Carolines ont eu
à se prononcer sur le décès d'un
Français mort à l'étranger c'était
Jean-Patrick Giraud
devant un enfant mort il faut essayer de
redonner la parole à cet enfant qui est
mort c'est ça qui est important pour moi
au Québec en 2003 qui sera chargé de
redonner la parole à Jean Patrick
une jeune médecin qui débute à peine sa
pratique à l'autopsie la pathologie
stade n'a rien découvert aucune maladie
aucune blessure ni traumatisme cause de
décès indéterminé pour un enfant de 3
ans et demi en pleine santé
la conclusion de la pathologie Sauvageau
ou plutôt son absence de conclusion est
un cadeau du ciel pour Marie-Christine
Bugeaud et elle le sait les experts
madame Sauvageau puis monsieur
charrette que moi je remets pas en doute
leurs compétences c'est des experts à
leurs yeux
j'avais été criminalisé seriez-vous
m'arrêter le lundi soir
Marie-Christine Bugeaud avait raison
elle ne sera finalement accusée de rien
du tout en l'absence d'une cause de
décès claire la procureur de l'époque
Hélène Morin choisit de ne pas déposer
d'accusation dans le cadre de cette
enquête nous avons consulté trois
pathologistes judiciaires Canadiens tous
estiment que la noyade était une forte
possibilité et aurait dû être mentionnée
dans le rapport d'autopsie pourtant
aucune contre expertise n'a été demandé
par la procureur et en France on se
demande bien pourquoi le procureur il a
les moyens il a les moyens d'ordonner
des expertises complémentaires il a les
moyens de demander une contre-expertise
quand il est pas satisfait complètement
des conclusions il le fait d'ailleurs en
France le procureur on aurait pu aller
au fond des choses au Canada aussi c'est
ce que vous dites il me semble il me
semble que la procureur Hélène Morin a
été nommé juge elle a refusé de répondre
à nos questions
l'enquête est donc classée avec regret
comme l'indique les notes de l'enquêteur
Yves Beaulieu quelques mois plus tard le
coronaire René Charest ferme lui aussi
le dossier
comment cette autopsie a-t-elle été
traitée par le Laboratoire des sciences
judiciaires et qui est la médecin au
cœur de cette affaire c'est la
pathologie Annie Sauvageau embauché
seulement quelques mois auparavant il
s'agit d'une de ses premières autopsies
d'enfants pour le laboratoire si c'est
un cas qui était d'emblée suspect
domicile à ce moment-là il aurait
peut-être fallu qu'il y ait un senior
qui travaille avec elle de façon à être
sûr que tout a été fait que tout a été
bien fait que tout a été regardé sur ce
point Annie Sauvageau nous a répondu par
écrit
le cas a été révisé et discuté à fond
avec le directeur André Lozon et avec
d'autres pathologistes judiciaires de
l'équipe et tous étaient d'accord avec
mes conclusions
il a également été révisé à l'Hôpital
Sainte-Justine par un pathologiste
pédiatrique
[Musique]
rejoins cette semaine le docteur Lauzon
affirme n'avoir aucun souvenir d'avoir
révisé ou discuté de ce cas il admet
qu'une possibilité de noyade aurait dû
être inscrite au rapport d'autopsie
à votre avis quel rôle a joué le rapport
d'autopsie d'Annie Sauvageau dans la
fermeture du dossier c'était la clé
parce que
c'était la clé tout cadrait si j'ose
dire pour pointer à un homicide sauf ce
rapport qui n'arrivait pas à conclure
Julien Géraud décide alors de prendre
les choses en main et il aura besoin
d'une alliée ça fait très longtemps que
Julien Géraud est venu me voir ça
remonte à peu près à 20 ans je me
souviens toujours de ce premier instant
ce premier rendez-vous ce moment fort de
cet homme qui vient me voir
qui est totalement désespéré
est une grosse pointure des affaires
criminelles et politiques françaises et
une présence régulière à la télévision
moi il y a une démission des parents
mais on constate aussi qu'il y a une
démission du Coran saignant le premier
levier qu'elle utilisera pour son client
sera celui de sa citoyenneté le fils de
Julien Giroud était canadien mais aussi
français la nationalité française du
Petit Jean Patrick des déterminante
parce que si cet enfant avait été
canadien seulement évidemment la France
ne pouvait pas s'ingérer dans les
affaires judiciaires canadiennes en
France contrairement au Canada une
victime collatérale a le droit d'exiger
que la justice enquête c'est ce que va
faire Julien Géraud l'Odyssée sera
longue parce que le Canada envoie les
documents au compte-goutte
c'est pas possible je ne peux pas
m'entendre dire que on peut pas obtenir
un dossier et puis quoi encore et qu'on
peut pas regarder ce qu'il y a dedans et
qu'on peut pas aller plus loin c'est
impossible donc j'insiste mais la France
ne semble pas presser non plus il faudra
5 ans pour qu'un juge mandatte une de
ses meilleures expertes médicaux légales
la docteur Caroline rit salement de
l'Hôtel-Dieu de Paris prend connaissance
du dossier en 2008 pour les Français
les Canadiens sont mythiques en matière
de mauvais traitement pour les enfants
en matière d'autopsie en matière de
sciences médico-judiciaire et là j'étais
extrêmement déçu parce que justement je
m'attendais à avoir un rapport tellement
fouillé tellement précis tellement
circonstancié et là je n'avais que cette
feuille de papier et de rapport sommaire
elle doit répondre à la question que
tout le monde se pose de quoi
Jean-Patrick est-il mais il lui manque
des éléments notamment des prélèvements
effectués sur le corps du petit mon plus
vieux souvenir de cette affaire c'est
ma frustration
à ne pas obtenir les pièces qui étaient
nécessaires pour faire un travail
correct même si je pensais
à une noyade
je ne pouvais pas en fournir la preuve
sans dossier complet la docteur et
salmon n'a pas le choix elle remet en
2010 les mêmes conclusions que ça
concerne québécoise Annie Sauvageau
il n'est pas possible d'affirmer que
Jean-Patrick Géraud est décédé d'une
noyade vous croyez que vous alliez en
rester là je pensais que j'allais en
rester là et je n'étais très frustré
aussi
un an plus tard la France s'apprête à
fermer le dossier définitivement lorsque
Caroline rice allemand reçoit un appel
inespéré j'ai eu la surprise
que le juge d'instruction me téléphone
il me dit j'ai reçu un colis du Canada
je crois que ce sont vos lames
je lui ai dit bougez pas j'arrive j'ai
traversé le parvis parce que je suis
allée dans le bureau du juge et j'ai
pris possession du fameux carton que
trouve-t-on dans cette boîte des
lamelles de verre avec à l'intérieur des
prélèvements des poumons de
jean-Patrique Giraud qu'est-ce que ça a
changé le contenu de cette boîte le
contenu de cette boîte ça a changé que
je m'étais pas trompé et que la clé
était dans la boîte la clé ce sont les
lames que Caroline rissalmont va
transmettre à sa collègue de toujours la
docteur Caroline Rambaud spécialiste des
autopsies pédiatriques c'était je veux
dire si c'était simple
c'était très simple c'était un poumon
caractéristique d'une asphyxie et donc
il y avait toutes les lésions qu'il
fallait pour faire le diagnostic et ça
m'a posé de problème on va grossir
dessus ce que vous voyez à l'écran ce
sont les alvéoles du poumon de
Jean-Patrick Giraud entre chaque petit
sac d'air les cloisons sont rompus l'air
ne peut pas entrer le poumon continue à
s'agrandir mais il s'acclate à
l'intérieur c'est un signe d'asphyxie
mais pour prouver la noyade il faut
aller plus loin on va chercher des
éléments qui pourraient aller contre ou
aller pour et avec le docteur Rey on a
trouvé que des éléments qui allaient en
faveur de la noyade un de ces éléments
c'est la spum un mélange de mucus d'air
et d'eau qui crée une écume de mousse
typique dénoyade la docteur Sauvageau
l'avait relevé dans son rapport sans
expliquer sa présence
Julien Géraud finit par obtenir en 2016
ce qu'il cherche depuis si longtemps
Marie-Christine Bugeaud est accusé en
France du meurtre de leur fils Jean
Patrick
après la pause une accusation un procès
mais pas de justice
malgré tout il reste quand même beaucoup
de d'amertume que les autorités
canadiennes et n'est pas participé
davantage à la manifestation de la
vérité
[Musique]
revenons à la pathologie au cœur du
dossier de jean-Patrique Annie Sauvageau
on examinait son parcours professionnel
au Canada on a lu des jugements parler à
d'autres pathologies des avocats
plusieurs remèdes sont travail en
question et c'est conclusions ne font
pas le poids face aux expertes du père
de Jean Patrick
la mère de Jean-Patrick est accusée en
France 15 ans après que le Canada est
fermé le dossier pendant tout ce temps
la carrière de la pathologie Sauvageau
progresse en 2011 elle pratique à
Edmonton et elle a monté en grade mon
invité Annie Sauvageau est médecin
légiste en chef en Alberta je la joie
dans nos studios d'adminton madame
Sauvageau bonjour bonjour
en 2011 Radio-Canada reçoit la nouvelle
patronne du bureau du médecin légiste de
l'Alberta Annie Sauvageau évoque sa
passion pour son domaine de recherche
l'asphyxie et la strangulation quand on
sait que quelqu'un est mort par ce
strangulation disons cette angulation
manuelle donc combien de temps que ça
prend pour que la personne meurt elle
fonde aussi le programme de pathologies
judiciaire de l'Université de l'Alberta
son parcours semble fasciner les médias
de tout le pays Annie Sauvageau devient
la star de la pathologie judiciaire au
Canada
ce système dont elle est fière Annie
Sauvageau va vouloir le réformer mais
son approche ne fait pas l'unanimité et
ça crée des conflits avec la police de
carglery
normalement les médecins légistes et les
policiers collaborent pour faire avancer
l'enquête mais ce n'est pas ce qui s'est
produit dans le cas de la petite make-4
Jordan l'enfant de 6 ans a été battu à
mort en 2012
l'autopsie reste flou sur un aspect très
important l'heure et le jour de son
décès la police de carguruy a besoin
d'un pathologiste plus habitué au décès
d'enfants et elle le trouve à
l'extérieur de la province
est un éminent pathologiste judiciaire
britannique il pratique maintenant à
l'hôpital général d'Ottawa pour aider la
police de Calgary dans l'enquête make-4
Jordan le docteur Milroy avait
évidemment besoin de l'autopsie réalisée
par une pathologie de l'équipe d'anis
Sauvageau mais la docteur Sauvageau
refuse de transmettre le dossier
le blocage dure six mois puis les
détectives prennent les grands moyens un
mandat de perquisition pour forcer le
bureau du docteur Sauvageau à
transmettre le dossier d'autopsie à son
collègue d'Ottawa entre la police et la
médecine c'est la guerre
le juge force finalement l'institution à
partager le dossier d'autopsie c'est un
point tournant dans l'enquête car le
docteur Milroy réussi à préciser le jour
du décès de l'enfant résultat le père et
la belle-mère de la petite sont
condamnés tous les deux pour meurtre
une
n'est pas le seul à remettre en question
le travail Dany Sauvageau
en France Julien Giraud maintient la
pression auprès des médias
tout à fait
dans la baignoire
on a du mal à imaginer
une maman qui fait ça à son fils oui
voilà et c'est certainement une des
raisons pour lesquelles elle a peut-être
pas été mise en accusation plutôt sur la
cause de la mort de Jean-Patrick la
justice française va vouloir aller au
fond des choses une juge d'instruction
va donc interroger Annie Sauvageau par
écrit en 2013 la juge lui demande ce
qu'elle pense de l'opinion de ses
collègues Rambaud et récemment l'enfant
aurait été noyé anis Sauvageau admet que
la noyade est une possibilité mais elle
insiste l'autopsie judiciaire ne permet
en aucune manière de prouver le
diagnostic mais mon opinion
professionnelle est que de conclure à
une mort par noyade sur ses observations
n'est pas scientifiquement valide la
Québécoise écarte complètement les
conclusions de ces concerts selon Annie
Sauvageau les fameuses lames ne prouvent
rien il s'agit seulement d'une croyance
française pour prouver la noyade il faut
exclure tout le reste qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ça je réponds que bien sûr à
la raison donc on est bien d'accord et
le travail d'exclusion des autres causes
potentielles d'asphyxie a été fait il
n'y a aucun signe de strangulation de
suffocation ou d'autres traumatismes sur
le corps du petit ne reste donc que la
noyade pour expliquer l'écume de mousse
et l'état des poumons de Jean Patrick ce
champignon de mousse de noyer et
vraiment c'était un argument très fort
pour moi donc je c'est pour ça aussi que
je voulais absolument avoir ces lames
l'opinion québécoise et l'opinion
française seront débattus au procès de
Marie-Christine Bugeaud qui aura lieu en
aura le temps de pas à lire car en
Alberta plus rien ne va entre le
ministère de la Justice et la pathologie
en 2014 son contrat de médecin légiste
en chef n'est pas renouvelé elle
réplique avec une poursuite de 7
millions et demi de dollars contre son
employeur
depuis elle gagne sa vie comme
consultante en pathologie judiciaire son
rôle d'expert est parfois critiqué
notamment lorsqu'elle témoigne en faveur
de parents accusés d'avoir tué ou
négligé leur enfant comme le couple
Clark
étaient de retour en cours aujourd'hui à
Cagliari pour les audiences de
détermination de leur peine le couple a
été reconnu coupable en octobre dernier
de négligence criminelle causant la mort
de leur fils de 14 mois l'enfant est
mort d'une septicémie une infection
grave négligée pendant des semaines cinq
médecins témoignent à cet effet anis
Sauvageau les contredits tous les cinq
et blâme l'hôpital plutôt que les
parents pour le décès du bébé le couple
est quand même condamné et en appel le
juge critique l'expertise Dany Sauvageau
elle n'a pas révisé toute la preuve et
dans certaines parties de son témoignage
elle se prononce aux limites de son
expertise docteur Sauvageau fut un
témoin opiniâtre quereller et parfois
évasif
presque en même temps en 2019 le Québec
commence à s'intéresser à la faire
Bugeaud
une Québécoise soupçonnée du meurtre de
son fils a la Chine il y a 17 ans fait
maintenant l'objet d'un mandat d'arrêt
de la France
Christine bujot s'il vous plaît
moi-même nous avons rejoint
Marie-Christine Bugeaud en 2019 madame
bijoux je vous appelle parce que je suis
journaliste à l'émission Enquête et
je j'ai devant moi une ordonnance de
mise en accusation devant la Cour
d'assise de Paris et un mandat
d'arrestation vous concernant mon dieu
ça date de 15
OK
vous êtes au courant de l'ordonnance
non je suis pas au courant de rien vous
êtes en train de m'apprendre des choses
madame je parle de ton barbe ma chaise
madame Bugeaud savait pourtant depuis
trois ans qu'elle était accusée les
documents le prouve son process amorce à
Paris le 16 septembre 2019 17 ans après
la mort de son fils elle n'y assistera
pas parce que la loi française permet ce
qui est très rare ici le procès en
l'absence de l'accusé je suis sorti de
là en sachant absolument pas ce que ça
allait donner parce que j'y avais pas
d'accusé c'était vraiment vraiment
étrange comme comme atmosphère
on a défendu notre dossier face à la
démonstration magistrale des docteurs
Rambaud et récemment sur les causes de
la mort on est passé très vite enfin la
défense est passée très vite parce que
voilà c'était tellement évident
tellement éclatant que ça s'est traduit
par une condamnation à 25 avec les gens
criminelle j'étais
soulagée pour cet enfant
ce qui était important pour moi c'est
qu'on reconnaisse que cet enfant était
mort parce qu'il avait été noyé
ne reste que la dernière étape faire
extrader Marie-Christine Bugeaud pour
lui faire purger sa peine de 25 ans j'ai
demandé l'extradition de Madame Pujol
mais les autorités canadiennes ont
toujours répondu qu'il ne donnerait pas
suite à cette demande malgré tout il
reste quand même beaucoup de d'amertume
que les autorités canadiennes et n'est
pas participé davantage à la
manifestation de la vérité
[Musique]
au retour on va vous révéler ce qui est
arrivé à Marie-Christine Bugeaud la mère
de jean-Patrique
ils ont jamais pu se parler il n'a
jamais pu lui poser les questions qu'il
taraude
elle est partie avec son secret en fait
il y a trois ans notre équipe a commencé
à s'intéresser à la mort de
jean-Patrique et à documenté le rôle
qu'a joué le rapport de Topsy Dany
Sauvageau en cette affaire mais plus
récemment un événement est venu relancer
l'enquête le témoignage Dany Sauvageot
pour la belle-mère de la petite fille de
Granby
[Musique]
l'affaire a bouleversé tout le Québec
martyrisé par sa famille et négligée par
l'État la petite fille de Granby a
incarné toutes les failles de notre
système de protection des enfants c'est
au procès de sa belle-mère ici à
Trois-Rivières que les orribles détails
ont été révélés l'enfant est morte par
suffocation externe à cause du ruban
adhésif à poser sur son nez et sa bouche
et c'est au même procès que nous
retrouvons un personnage central de
l'histoire de Jean-Patrick la pathologie
c'est un retour aux sources pour Annie
Sauvageau native de Trois-Rivières elle
a été retenue comme experte par l'équipe
de la belle-mère qui est accusée de
meurtre après une pause de deux semaines
la défense fait entendre depuis 14h son
dernier témoin c'est Annie Sauvageau
elle l'a été longtemps pathologiste
judiciaire pourquoi le procès a-t-il été
interrompu pendant deux semaines parce
qu'ani Sauvageau n'est plus médecin elle
a renoncé à son permis d'exercice en
2015 elle affirme que le permis n'est
pas nécessaire pour son métier de
consultante pourquoi vous n'avez pas de
licence je n'ai pas de licence parce que
je n'en ai pas besoin je ne tiens pas le
scalpel dans ma main on a besoin d'une
licence quand on touche à un corps
mais comme Annie Sauvageau se présente
comme médecin depuis 7 ans le procureur
de la Couronne veut l'empêcher de
témoigner ça fait 7 ans que madame n'a
pas touché un bistouri et autant
d'années qu'il n'y a pas de publication
dans son champ d'expertise on le trait
sous la ligne on va laisser ça aller
encore combien de temps sans intervenir
je pense qu'on ne pourrait pas voir en
France parce que dans dans les dossiers
criminels on ne nomme que des experts
qui restent dans l'exercice de leur
profession c'est à dire qu'un médecin
reste médecin s'il est plus médecin il
est plus médecin les compétences d'amis
sauvageaux sont remises en question et
le contenu de son rapport aussi par
exemple elle diagnostic un trouble
psychiatrique à la petite victime
qu'elle n'a pourtant jamais rencontré et
ça ne passe pas pour le procureur
elle n'a pas de permis elle fait des
diagnostics dans une science qui ne
relève pas de la sienne et elle manque
de rigueur ce qui semble le plus
inquiéter le juge Louis Dionne c'est la
possibilité de dérapage la réponse a pas
mal tout madame Sauvageau et c'est
dangereux ça il faut pas laisser croire
au jury que le témoin expert voit les
abnubiler avec un écran de fumée
le débat dure quatre jours la défense
tente même d'obtenir un arrêt des
procédures
finalement le juge va trancher le
rapport d'Annie Sauvageau est amputé de
moitié et le titre de docteur disparaît
de son CV mais comme elle a réalisé plus
de 3000 autopsies le juge d'ionne lui
accorde le statut d'expert elle pourra
témoigner à titre de consultante quelle
est la cause du décès de la petite on
sait qu'elle est morte suffoquée par le
ruban Gomé enroulé autour de son corps
mais la belle-mère a-t-elle accéléré la
mort de l'enfant en collant aussi du
ruban sur sa bouche Annie Sauvageau
croit que non elle contredit l'experte
de la Couronne et les témoins oculaires
sur ce point après un long débat
technique le juge d'ionne pose la
question clé madame Sauvageot
pardonnez-moi si je me trompais si on
n'utilise pas de ruban cette journée là
peu importe la façon on n'a pas de décès
c'est exact merci c'est ce que le jury
retiendra la belle-mère est reconnue
coupable de meurtre au deuxième degré et
la condamnation sera portée en appel
ce que le juge d'ionne n'a jamais su
pendant le procès c'est que quelques
semaines auparavant un autre juge avait
sérieusement remis en question
l'impartialité d'Annie Sauvageau
le témoignage de la docteur Sauvageau
reflète un manque d'objectivité et de
distance professionnelle ces propos nous
les avons trouvés dans le rapport d'une
enquête publique sur le décès de Lissa
Goldman une jeune femme en Alberta ici
encore Annie Sauvageau contre dit 5
médecins quant aux causes de la mort et
elle attaque personnellement une
collègue ce que la juge chargée de
l'enquête publique ne semble pas
apprécier la docteur Sauvageau a un
conflit d'intérêt dans cette cause comme
le fondement du statut d'expert est
l'indépendance et l'impartialité je
donne peu d'importance à son opinion
dans ce milieu il s'agit d'une critique
grave
[Musique]
des meurtres impunis comme celui de
Jean-Patrick Giraud
[Musique]
Annie Sauvageau a pris sa retraite au
mois d'août elle a refusé de nous
accorder une entrevue
le reste de l'histoire appartient aux
parents de Jean Patrick
il y aura quand même toujours un
chapitre non écrit dans ce livre
qu'il ne peut pas se refermer vraiment
parce que
ils ont jamais pu se parler il n'a
jamais pu lui poser les questions qu'il
taraude
elle est partie avec son secret en fait
j'ai essayé de la contacter
pour avoir une espèce d'ultime
conversation avec elle vous partir en un
peu plus en paix on peut pas dire
certaines choses
mais bon j'ai pas j'ai pas pu lui parler
Marie-Christine Bugeaud est décédé en
janvier dernier d'un cancer au cerveau
l'existence de son fils n'a pas été
mentionné assez funérailles c'est donc à
Julien Géraud que revient le fardeau de
garder Jean Patrick vivant qui pense
encore à lui à part peut-être nous ici
maintenant et moi mais voilà
viendra rapidement le jour ou plus
personne ne saura qu'il ne saura qu'il a
qu'il a existé
sa mémoire mérite d'être honorée voilà
sa mémoire mérite d'être honoré
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié le
reportage de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
je vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]